*renifle*
Vous trouvez pas que ça sent la compilation de jeu un peu là ?
Je dirais même de jeux gratuits, Lucas Hauchard, eh oui !
Et on commence avec un jeu incroyable qui s'appelle "ce jeu avec des explosions et des slow motions"
C'est vraiment le nom du jeu, hein !
Ça a été fait par les mecs qui ont fait "Totally Accurate Battle Simulator" et "Clustertruck" et ça a l'air extrêmement cool.
Le but est très simple, il y a un pavillon en train d'exploser,
au ralenti en slow motion, voilà comme ça,
et il faut pénétrer dedans... Et mourir.
Il faut sauter sur les cailloux, voilà, pour pénétrer dans le bâtiment... Et trouver le chat.
Le problème c'est qu'on sait pas où est le chat.
Allez allez escalade (×4) !
Il est où !? Dammit !
Un humain... On s'en bat les couilles, c'est le chat qu'on veut sauver ! *rire*
Paix aux animaux !
Attends le building est en train d'exploser salement ! Il faut que je me dépêche !
Je parie que le chat est tout en haut, hein, clairement...
Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font putain !? Les mecs sont morts !
Vas-y je les sauve, on n'est pas des brigands, mec.
Putain mais attends, il va mourir, le mec, là où je l'ai envoyé !
Allez MONTE ! Il est sur le toit le chat ?
IL EST LÀ ! Et alors ?
C'est quoi ça ?
Aaaah, c'est tout ce que je viens de faire en sens inverse !
Y a qu'un level ? Mais non y a pas qu'un level !
Mais c'est le jeu le plus stylé de la vidéo, faut pas qu'il y ait qu'un level ! *rire*
Ma vidéo tombe à l'eau !
Ah si à chaque fois c'est le même immeuble qui explose, en fait ! D'accord !
Ok on y va.
On va essayer de la faire en mode... En passant sur les morceaux de ciment, c'est beaucoup plus stylé.
Oh là là, OH LÀ LÀ ! Oh là ça fait tellement super-héros comme ça, mec !
*musique épique*
Hop là, on passe, on va grimper sur ce caillou...
DAMMIT ! C'est pas facile d'être Hancock mon gars...
Vous connaissez Hancock ? Attention je parle pas de Bangkok, je parle pas de Thaïlande, hein...
Ok le caillou qui est là on va s'appuyer dessus !
Il nous fait monter à l'étage supérieur ! Qui nous permet...
Y a plus de mec ? Putain, merde, c'est aléatoire en fait !
Vite il me faut des débris ! S'il vous plaît des débris ! Comme dans H1Z1,
pour construire ton petit Kevlar, pour pas te faire one shot
OH !! Oh non !
Je l'ai pas sauvé donc j'ai perdu ! Dammit !!
Attends mais c'est pas facile ce jeu aussi là
Parce que en fait je peux mourir, j'ai l'impression
que je suis invincible mais pas du tout
En fait l'explosion remonte petit à petit hein, même si on dirait pas
Hop là c'est ... pfff mais mec je l'ai jeté dans l'explosion !!
Putain le pire sapeur pompier du monde
Ok là y'a qui ?
Viens par là
ÇA DÉGAGE !!
Je suis désolé .. HOOO !!
Je l'ai sauvé au péril de ma vie !
*musique triste*
Bah j'imaginais plus une médaille qu'un sandwich triangle
... mais pourquoi pas !!
Y'a une question qui trotte dans ma tête
Elle est même au galop si tu vois ce que je veux dire
Êtes-vous un vrai geek ?
Un vrai "nerd"
Parce que quand on dit "nerd" c'est plus stylé que geek
Alors j'entends des "OUI" par là
là pas trop, bon écoutez...
Le mec part en one man show devant un public qui n'existe pas, génial !
Ce troisième jeu s'intitule "PC BUILDING SIMULATOR"
Pas de panique à bord, je vais vous traduire le titre
parce que c'est quand même dur à traduire ça veut dire "CONSTRUIRE UN PC SIMULATOR"
Voilà.
On a 2000 $, on va faire un putain de PC gamer ensemble mon pote !
On le fera gagner à la fin de la vidéo !
Bah nan.
Pas dans la vraie vie. Je ferai gagner le pc DU JEU.
J'enverrai ma sauvegarde du jeu quoi si tu veux.
On va prendre une carte graphique, la "Asus GTX 680 Direct".
Oh le jeu a été fait il y a dix mille ans !
Ils sont dans les 680, aujourd'hui on est dans les 1000.
C'est ti-par, la graphic card, on va la foutre du coup...
Ah y a même pas de... Nan pardon y a pas de carte mère encore !
Ah bah oui ! Une carte graphique ne peut pas marcher s'il y a pas de carte mère !
La carte mère c'est ce sur quoi tu fous ta RAM, ton processeur, ton truc... Enfin c'est ce qui relie TOUT !
Nan mais j'explique ! J'explique, les amis.
Et moi une fois j'ai acheté une carte graphique, je l'ai mise moi-même dans mon pc, OKAY ?!
Et j'ai dû me décharger en électricité statique avant de l'ouvrir pour pas heu... Cramer mon pc.
Enfin j'avais lu ça donc je me suis déchargé en électricité.
Alors ! "Motherboards". Je suppose que c'est ça, Motherboards.
Mère des boards.
Hop là ! On l'a mise.
Attention, ce tutoriel est factice, hein.
N'allez pas commander les composants d'un pc pour le construire dans la vraie vie en vous basant sur ce que je fais là, hein ! *rire*
Je veux pas être responsable des milliers d'euros perdus.
Une fois qu'on a mis la carte mère, on va mettre la ASUS.
Bien évidemment, juste ici.
Une fois que la carte mère est mise... La carte graphique, pardon. Je dis n'importe quoi.
La carte graphique est en place, on peut presque lancer BF1 en ultra
MAIIIIS il faut aussi l'aide... d'un processeur !!
Voiiiilàààà, on s'est compris.
"Memory". On met la RAM, c'est ici.
Alors là, je me souviens, il faut appuyer sur ces petits trucs blancs
pour débloquer l'accès, mettre la RAM et reverrou... Normalement ça se verrouille tout seul par contre. Ouais, voilà.
Eh on voit quand même que j'ai monté un PC !
Eh j'me sens frais, frère ! Eh j'vais pécho des meufs grâce à ça !
On va rajouter une autre barrette... Non pas de shit, jeune délinquant, mais de RAM
Bien sûr, bien évidemment !
Une fois que c'est fait, il va falloir mettre un disque duuuur
Pour mettre un disque dur, ça se met ici ! Ça c'est des slots de disques durs.
Alors on va le mettre juste là !
Disque dur physique, ou alors SSD si vous voulez que ce soit un petit peu plus rapide, hein !
On est gourmand, on se met bien cousin, on en met plusieurs !
Ah on n'a pas les thunes ! C'est mort, on n'a pas les thunes.
On va ensuite mettre une alimentation, qui va bien sûr alimenter le PC !
Une 500 Watts ?! Normalement faut mettre un peu plus que 500 W pour un PC Gamer, mais bon... Hinhinhinhin !
Amateurs, les gens qu'ont fait le jeu !
Il faut ensuite mettre un petit ventilateur de manière à ventiler le tout !
Ça se met juste là ! C'est toujours ce truc-là qu'est plein de poussière sur ton PC.
Eh oui, regarde, vas-y ! Vas-y, je te laisse le temps !
MAIS POURQUOI T'AS ACHETÉ UN PC PORTABLE AUSSI ?!!
Une fois que ça c'est fait, on va mettre un CPU cooler, juste là.
Voilà ! Qui permet bien sûr de rafraichir le processeur, parce que ça chauffe énormément, un processeur, bien évidemment !
Comme tout ce qu'il y a dans ce putain de PC !
Et que tu devras changer dans deux ans parce que ça aura tellement chauffé que ce sera usé !
Est-ce qu'on met deux cartes graphiques ? Allez on met deux cartes graphiques on est gourmand ! VOILÀÀÀÀ !
On veut de la puissaaaance !!
On fait un SLI comme on appelle ça !
SLI bien sûr qui est l'abréviation de Salement Limité Imbécile,
parce qu'avoir un SLI ne double pas la puissance de ton PC, mais ça l'augmente de 20% dans les jeux, voilà.
Contrairement aux idées reçues. Eh ouais !
Peut-être que les puristes veulent m'insulter parce que c'est 22% et pas 20,
ou peut-être 30, je ne sais pas... ACHETEZ SAN PELLEGRINO. Alors.
On va mettre un ventilo ici aussi, pour le plaisir, parce que ça nous amuse, bien sûr.
Sachant que ton PC est collé au sol, il sert un peu à rien. En vrai y a même pas de ventilo ici... Enfin j'crois.
Peut-être que je dis encore une fois de l'énorme merde. Mais y a pas de ventilo, ici, putain !
Ouais y a pas de ventilo du tout ici !
Oh "Thermal Paste", la pâte thermique, qu'on a oubliée bien sûr.
Donc heu... Le processeur va instant cramer ! C'est pas grave !
On va ensuite mettre la Drive Cover, tu sais c'est ces petites plaques que tu retires de ton PC en appuyant dessus.
Voilà je viens d'ouvrir le mien, mais je peux pas vous la montrer elle reste attachée au PC...
Une fois que les plaques sont mises, on n'a pas de lecteur CD ! Ah bah t'es déçu
Pourquoi t'es déçu Théodore, parce que tu pourras pas lire le DVD Twilight que ton père t'as offert pour ton anniversaire,
c'est triste ! C'est comme ça, t'iras sur eMule, hein, parce qu'on est en 2002 dans cette vidéo !
Ensuite, tu mets le side panel, bien évidemment.
Bien sûr avec une petite vitre, parce que tu veux que quand les gens viennent chez toi,
ils voient ta carte graphique, et ta mémoire RAM, bien sûr !
Les amis le PC est totalement prêt, y a plus qu'à l'envoyer à celui qui me l'avait commandé !
Et voilà on a fait un heureux aujourd'hui, tout en apprenant des choses aux gens !
À moi Battlefield 1 en ultra !
Ok maintenant on joue ! Plus qu'à l'allumer, et BF1 est à nouuus !
*BOUUUUUUUUUM*
Y avait peut-être pas assez de RAM, là dans le pc...
Et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu, moi je me suis bien marré !
Merci d'avoir regardé, vous savez maintenant comment monter un PC pour qu'il explose littéralement au moment où vous l'allumez,
donc ne suivez surtout pas ce tuto, je le répète c'est important !
Par contre y a sûrement des mecs qui ont fait des tutos pour monter son PC sur Youtube, et ce sont des vrais tutos,
que vous pouvez suivre, hein, contrairement à celui-ci.
Allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde...!
Ouais on finit sur un mec qui se gratte calmement, bon voilà...
Allez à bientôt les amis !